alors alors alors je n'ose pas regarder
parce que c'est le moment on va
découvrir le fruit de huit heures de
travail les vieux on en est où on en est
où là on est en train d'en créer la lino
olala mais ça y est effectivement qui
est déjà bien grave et c'est génial
et oui et quand tu passes la peinture
d'un coup tout est révélée way cauchemar
lancre d'un seul coup le dessin apparaît
alors lettre un visionnement fascinant à
regarder
mais tu vas avoir un positif et tu
passes ta presse c'est génial mais c'est
trop beau c'est tellement délicat et
c'est tellement précis donc on retrouve
effectivement les thèmes de la tradition
et de la modernité parce qu'en effet sur
une vanité avec un gros sandwich avec
des frites maintenant que c'est grave et
je peux faire le tirage autant de fois
que je veux avec autant de couleurs que
je veux avec autant de da proches que je
vais autant de papier que je veux autant
de deux façons de le faire différentes
mais alors est-ce que ça encore de la
valeur quand ça peut être démultipliée
alain oui si tu prends la gravure comme
ça tirait à l'exemplaire multiplier a
pas forcément beaucoup de valeur par
contre si tu l'as réhausse d'aquarelles
en une seule
un seul tirage unique là oui ça prend un
peu plus de valeur - est-ce que tu peux
m'en faire une qui a pas trop de valeur
parce que je mérite pas plus que ça
juste je te laisse ouvert l'impression
alors que le faire oui génial j'adore
c'est vraiment le genre de chose qui me
passait pas
[Musique]
bah
c'est magnifique bravo christelle merci
d'avoir relever notre défi renversant
d'allier la tradition et la modernité
merci beaucoup